and that's why Crowder said silence is
consent and I thought to myself when I
watch it there this morning I was like
whoa dude because that's what the left
has been saying I hear what you what you
mean mm-hmm I get it man I don't like
the idea like that but but but but he's
it's true man now I left the left when
they say it because they're they're out
screaming top of their lungs they're not
silent yeah and now and now we're seeing
you know crowd even crowd was coming out
and saying it I got to tell you man from
from hearing from especially a lot of
people in the Chad and the super chat
about Trump yeah I'm not convinced he's
gonna win at this point I was thinking
landslide for a long time watching
everything yeah but then I started
talking the Trump supporters okay I
started I started you know I reached out
to a friend of mine and they said no way
I'm not voting for him again
and I'm like really hmm yeah I'll tell
you this I took a walk earlier today and
I saw a lot of Trump's signs for sure I
I walk around our neighborhood a lot
yeah I've never seen him you know we're
in a blue district but now arena blue
district where we're at a heavy blue
district well let me tell you there's
Trump signs all over our neighborhood
now yeah I didn't see them two weeks ago
three weeks ago it was a it was like I
was like oh look there's a Trump
supporters around here like here's a
lady right there's a lake nearby I
remember this somebody went into the
middle of the lake it's like it's like
in the middle of a highway you have a
weird and they stuck a giant Trump flag
and under the lay center of the lake
there's no dock like somebody's
commitment that was yes that was
committing I'm doing it yeah
they committed to that but but look
there's a lot of signs so here's what
here's what I'm feeling I've seen all
these things and I'm like Trump
landslide dude riots
explosions insults division oh yeah and
then I started seeing a bunch of Trump
supporters like man some people that I
really really like high-profile people
being like nope
okay and it you know it could be it
could be that they're trying to make
sure hubris doesn't stand in trumps way
yeah because if everyone is so convinced
he'll win I'll be like I don't need to
vote he'll win and that's it and so they
need to maintain maybe maybe I don't
know though man but man I think he's
gonna win
here's crazy the people who are
complaining about Trump are complaining
he doesn't do enough right so what you
basically have are conservatives
demanding a stronger strong men yep more
authority yeah so III was reading some
threads and it was interesting because
some people were saying like I saw some
tweets from people saying that they
weren't going to support Trump anymore
yeah he's let them down and the response
from someone else was do you have any
idea what will happen if Trump doesn't
win if the Republicans don't win it's
like you may be upset that the
Republicans aren't doing anything yeah
but at least they're holding back what
could be scary if the Democrats get in
it's a good at this point yeah so so
I'll tell you what man you look at the
Democrats ten years ago and they were
saying very similar things to Trump even
Bernie Sanders and then the rise of the
far left happened and then all you got
to do is just take a google search
democrats neil we should call them all
laughs they've been called on that for a
long time I haven't heard that but the
alt left was a reference to the
identitarian left that's what it is yeah
and they got really mad about it and
they were like it's not fair you can't
call step because the alt-right calls
themselves all right no Mike I don't
care what you whatever I want
good yep well I'm gonna start using it
for now yeah but they are right there's
no difference there they're trying to
divide us they're making like shoving
race down well it's a gating us like I
don't want to be segregated I I like
someone on their their valor of their
heart and their mind that's what makes a
character not your skin color right
right yep period yeah it's it's so
they're all left well look it's a
reference to identity rien ISM okay yeah
all right vegetarian right alt left
identitarian left and it's freaky man
you know III it's just you do people
don't realize what that means
to live in a live with this racial
policy stuff it is it is
authoritarianism to the max it is it is
there's a there's an overlap with
communism they won't let you change your
circumstances you are
you are nah that you know I'm not cool
with that I am of the persuasion that we
are all dealt a card of hands in life
well we're all dealt a hand of cards
that sounds terrible yeah a card with
hands I felt a hand of cards yeah there
we go and sometimes you get a really bad
hand you know I'll tell you what man
I've watched some pretty good poker
games where I do does a trash hand and
he wins the pot mm-hmm yeah and that
means you may come from bad
circumstances and you can you can make
it yeah that's America yeah think about
the race based policy dude III it was my
mind that my friends that I talked to
periodically when I try to explain to
them what what what they're doing and
why it's bad and racist and they're
convinced they're better Harvard for
instance won the right to discriminate
based on race straight up seriously yeah
they were B so Harvard has a high
density of Asians okay there were so
they created a program because I we have
too many Asians we need to get more you
know we need to get more Latinos and
black students okay so they they set
lower thresholds in order to in order if
you're an Asian and you want to get into
Harvard you got to score like a 1330 on
the SATs Wow yeah that's like what
Oxford is doing now they're like oh if
you're black you don't have to do as
much work you want to know why this is
horrifying excuse me how degrading is
that you don't have to work as hard
because you can't you can't do what any
other race is doing like excuse me how
is that not crazy racism right there let
me tell you Oxford here's here's a new
here's the left says when you bring up
the Asian thing they say what we're
trying to create equality and there's
too many Asians there right and my
responses are they Ron Ian's are they
Indian are the Chinese Laotian
Vietnamese Japanese what do you mean by
Asia what does that mean
no we clump them all together exactly
same and so here's they don't tell you
what they don't tell you is that the
Asians at Harvard are are wealthy Indian
immigrants okay and wealthy Chinese
immigrants and so what they're what
they're telling you I here's what I say
to my friends is like do me a favor
you're okay with this institutional
racism all right
I know I know a kid 13 years old from
the south side of Chicago living in the
gutter friend of mine got a kid okay
they're poor I want you to go to that
kid look him right in the eyes and say
honey you can't go to Harvard because
you look too much like that person
that's it that's the only reason why you
can't do that
that's a and that's the left has won it
didn't used to be that way you know it
used to be that way a long time ago
yeah decades ago we won we pass laws you
can't do it right we are we're all
created equal the kind of your character
not the color your skin boom and here
comes the Democrats yeah it's not
winning where did we lose that and how
are people fighting for that for
Democrats when what when did when did
they stop being racist they never did it
just changed it over ya Biden Biden has
said even in the past month if you ain't
if you ain't voting for me if you
haven't figured out that you're voting
for me you ain't black it's like excuse
me what did you just say dude who is
ain't kidding me who is that Republican
we just watched was it sean Parnell is
that it's Sean right now yeah that ad
that it was amazing it was great well so
there's a Republican named sean Parnell
and it's it's a really great I was going
viral people were shaking like crazy but
he like walks up to a screen and he's
like I'll never tell you who you should
vote for based on your race or your
ethnicity and then he looks and then it
shows Joe Biden saying it yeah and then
he's like he shrugs and he walks away
yeah you see what they they said about
what's it what's the Senators name Tom
Scott Tom Scott yeah the Tim Scott Tim
Scott I believe who has a great name
yeah I know they they they called his
police reform plan a token gesture so
food Oh cuz people sicken me man but
they don't have any they don't have any
ideas themselves the Democrats a lot of
these people screeching oh for sure they
don't have any ideas they don't know
what they're screeching for they don't
even know what they're screeching for
yep do they notice they're using words
like token that's my question they do
right you remember that video we talked
about that that like 18 year old girl
getting arrested and hyperventilating
and they're like she needs her dialysis
oh the Begay do crime right
all right okay that video they shot
racial slurs at the at the cops straight
up I'm like dude I went to I went to
rally in Los Angeles I think it was a
black lives matter rally okay and Trump
supporters were having their own March I
kept my brakes I thought it was
everybody was marching and then two
groups come together and the cops kept
them separated okay
and there were guess what the Trump
group was ethnically diverse okay didn't
really mean anything to me I don't know
ever yeah I didn't think twice until I
heard the left start screaming racial
slurs - Wow like hard n-word that's
great a bunch of other things I can't
say the c-word
they got words for it man this is what
Terry Crews was talking about yep the
words they use I won't even say and I
think the left like excuse me the alt
left yes no I mean I'm sorry man hole
left it's it's fair toll on left it's
fair I guess to call them the alt left
but they take they've taken over yeah
like their ideology is pervasive you
know you like you know if you if you
don't bend the knee like they'll come
for you they'll take your job and so
yeah at a point it was alt left but now
I'll tell you what man they've started
purging media companies yep and and now
the high-ranking positions are being
dominated by these is this cult the
Washington Post announced that they're
opening up a whole bunch of new jobs
specifically for the new religion think
about that how would you feel if the New
York Times announced that they were
bringing on a new director of Judaism
literally and they're like they're gonna
they're gonna oversee our entire staff
to make sure there's enough Judaism in
our office people would flip out that'd
be so weird they'd they'd they would
necessarily flip out they'd be like
that's weird
now I'll tell you what are they did
Christianity oh then they look now me
not it would be except people be
throwing it flip out yeah but I just
mean you know I chose you teasing cuz
I'm just trying to bring up like any
religion okay you know like Buddhism
people would be like what why is a
newspaper gonna have a director that
oversees all of the staff and makes sure
they're all talking about Buddhism
enough I know it's just interesting
because they do seem awfully like anti
to you which is oh for sure man the
mainstream Farrakhan right the overlap
between the all right in the
man I want you to I want you all
listening to think for one second what
would you say to somebody if they
started you know showing off Nazi
imagery and iconography and symbols and
then you brought up the mainstreaming of
Hitler and they said well you know I
don't much care for him I mean he's a
bad guy but I really like what the party
is doing you'd be like what no way dude
I bet we could find quotes from
Farrakhan and quotes from Hitler and ask
people like which one is which we should
do that which one well to be fair
there's a lot of like just because
someone's evil doesn't mean you're not
gonna build to find a quote that someone
would agree with like that's not a dog
tis not that they agree with but who
said it if Hitler Hitler's evil and no
it wasn't evil what I mean is you can
find a quote from Farrakhan where he
says I sure do love a good cheeseburger
on a Sunday afternoon right and people
are gonna be like well well that's right
that's not really the quotes I
understand what you mean but what I'm
saying is there's probably a lot of
political quotes from Farrakhan that are
probably fine sure and that's and that's
the point like you could probably say
the same thing about Hitler but he's
still an evil person for sure that's why
the the James Lindsay and Bogosian and
Helen pluck Rose were able to take a
section of mine Kampf and change it to
feminist words right and they and they
ate it up yeah but that was actually a
really horrifying message though he went
they went for like one of the worst Wow
really people still ate it up yeah you
know there were something really funny
that happened in gullible 2016 somebody
took it was someone there was a letter
that was written about coming out to
their parents as a gay okay somebody
changed the word gay with Trump
supporter her and then like Trump
supporters started sharing it because
they're like wow cuz the like oh man it
was like I tried to tell my parents
today that I was supporting Trump and
they got not they would got so angry at
me they told me to get out they wouldn't
accept it and I'm like that's such a
weird thing yeah so weird I think
Brandon struck says that didn't he
doesn't like that like it was it was
easier to come out as gay than it was to
say you supported Trump a few people
have said that it's easier to come out
as being gay or like transgender than it
to come out as being oh yeah I think
Blair mentioned it too yeah yeah there
was that tweet that was floating around
last week it was like you get more like
crap for being a trump supporter than
being a minority yeah yeah now it is
unless you are I'm not saying it's true
or not I don't know but you know it's
been floating around mad people shared
it and it's like that's kind of in line
with what we're talking about if you are
a black Trump supporter mm-hmm
the left will use every racial slur in
the book I've seen him and I've seen I
try to follow a lot of different people
from all sides of the spectrum to get a
really good broad range of views from
everybody you know and it's like I don't
want one source I want all the sources
right you know and I'm seeing them out
there and they're like you know what we
don't care I don't care what they say
about me because I love my life I'm
successful and I'm like good for you
like good weren't the weren't the
eugenicist spread the Progressive Party
like the progressives were eugenicist
s-- in the early nineteen hundred's I
believe so I think and I know of a very
prominent progressive figure who is
still admired and revered by the far
left or at the far left and there's a
lot of progressives that are at
biogenics oh you mean the genesis a
prominent eugenicist
oh she was even a woman yeah it was very
nice and her name was Margaret Sanger
and she's still admired and revered by
the people at Planned Parenthood so hmm
yeah that's interesting
you know about genetics right yeah yeah
I do yeah that's messed up dude yes it
is she's only one I really know of
though so what what people with the
eugenicist people don't realize and
that's what my concern is like I wonder
how many of these left us are secretly
eugenicist s-- they don't realize that
homogenizing gene pools is actually
weakening the species yep they seem to
think that there's a path and that's
like no that's not the case you know no
we we get stronger by mixing our DNA
right that's survival outside women
people people last longer by mixing
their genes because you know I have I
have certain you know resistances to
certain things you know and the next
person might not we mix and create a
child that is stronger this is why yeah
they took diversity is a strength which
is factually true yep and they come
fleetly twisted it into a weird bizarro
zambia authoritarian nonsense yeah okay
I'll tell you what man it is double
speak let me ask you a question first
let's point out that the simple reality
of diversity we don't just mean genetics
we mean opinions ideas Thanks
the original idea was supposed to be
that if you had a dude who was from say
India or China okay and he came here
they'd be like I have seen the world in
a very different way from you let me
show you what I've seen and then you'll
be like wow I never thought of that
right so it's not just about their race
it was about who they were but yes there
have been many studies talking about us
like like an analogue to hybrid vigor in
in in mixed-race people's so these
things are true but let me ask you a
question if they really believed
diversity was a strength why would they
segregate farms and buildings and why
would they call for this weird
segregation type stuff because they're
liars
because they're they're manipulating
everybody they've pulled the was it to
pull the wool over their eyes or
whatever and so now you have people
saying things like this diversity is our
strength and you know they don't
actually mean that it's doublespeak you
know they're the ones actively trying to
equate an ork to a racial minority yeah
yeah that's messed up they don't really
believe diversity as a strength and I've
pointed this out too because Tucker
Carlson did a segment on this saying it
wasn't and and he made a good point
saying that cohesion is important and
working together and having a shared
culture is important it's like yes
you're absolutely right yeah we're a
melting pot that's what America is the
shared culture of America is the
umbrella of our Constitution and so long
as people come under that than we then
we're not falling apart but what my
rebuttal to that was Tucker has on
probably the most diverse set of
opinions for any cable show brian
Stelter of CNN he won't have on real
critics Rachel Matt I won't have on real
critics right none of them will Don
Lemon Anderson Cooper they won't well
Don Lemon I feel like he had that police
chief who ripped him apart and he was
regretting that exactly yeah he was like
we're gonna go to commercial he's not
saying what I want him to say Tucker
Carlson actively tries to get he does he
had the antifa dude on expunged graph
professor yeah that you're half
professor
neck yeah man and I'm like there it is
bro I was like you absolutely do
represent the strength in in having
different ideas come on and be
challenged and that's yeah diversity of
opinion that when you when you when you
homogenize things it weakens because
then your opportunity for finding a
solution is more limited but there
there's there's boundaries there's
limits right I'm not literally sang-taek
you know people from all over the world
put them in a room together shake it up
and see what happens I'm saying no we
have a constitution we have and in that
Constitution it says you shall smash the
like button oh yeah that is the
Constitution well the Constitution does
it not say that no our Constitution
sorry did I not specify no so III you
know I've made videos about this and
it's funny when they try and claim that
I'm not its it looked man I don't I
don't care people call me left or right
it literally is meaningless but I'll
tell you what
like even zoobi tweet it out zoobi the
rapper great dude yeah that
institutional racism and systemic
Grayson are real and they're pervasive
but it's probably too deep to get into a
big threat on Twitter yeah something
that effect yeah and I'm probably a
different perspective on him he's a
smart dude though he's really smart you
post a lot of smart ideas about what's
going on I thought a lot of people don't
want to address they wanted to skip what
he's cut the stuff that he's talking
about yep yeah so you know here what's
going on right now there are people who
are legit Center left left liberal
whatever yeah and they're like you know
the bretton Eric Weinstein people like
you and me probably zoobi well actually
I think zoobi as a conservative okay but
there's there's not and now it's just
called the politically homeless because
the left is now dominated by this fringe
dogmatic race base yeah I don't I don't
agree with a doublespeak you know and
conservatives have a bunch of views that
I mean a lot of my don't agree with same
here
however the the disagreements I have
with conservatives are relatively minor
compared to the threat of our
fundamental existence as a
freedom-loving people right so what
basically happens is the umbrella that
is America is under attack by forces
that are outside that umbrella so
liberals and conservatives look the
legit Americans actually there was that
those a graph
about this is really fascinating it
shows where Democratic voters were and
Trump voters were based on a spectrum of
social issues and economic issues okay
Trump voters we're we're all on the top
of social issues opposing social justice
narratives and authoritarianism but
spread out economically okay meaning you
literally have 50 50 if Trump supporters
between progressive
economics and more laissez-faire
economics but the Democrats were all
clustered in socialist social justice
Wow
so that's what I mean to say is there
are people who probably in 2008 voted
for Obama and what we definitely know
this for sure 10 million people went
from Obama to Trump and it's because you
have Trump's base is actually split up
between people who are just about
America but they disagree on should we
have higher taxes lower taxes should we
have better health like more taxpayer
funded health care type ideas public
option or universal versus private and
then you have the Democratic Party
social justice or whatever social
justice means thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune into this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you